do men deserve a bonus when they become
daddies the answer might surprise me hi
I'm Tim and this is science the show
where we buy test tubes and fill them
with all kinds of things at work today's
episode is about dads nature's test
tubes dads are pretty valuable people
they know how to light a grill they wear
ties and their dicks are huge at least
my Dez's recently the University of
British Columbia confirmed the
prevalence of the daddy bonus the wage
boosts that men enjoy when they become
fathers it sounds pretty great right raw
while dads do know a thing or two women
tend to earn less money when they become
mothers and as a big supporter of moms
that's just not cool because the study
found that these daddies often didn't
deserve that bonus when work performance
was more closely scrutinized for merit
pay the fatherhood wage boost was often
reduced or even reversed no longer just
a premium an escort service the daddy
bonus is here to steal your hard earned
money and the only way to stop it is an
experiment I like to call win back the
bacon from dead it's got a brand new
bacon
daddy's bacon it's super thick
daddy bacon money daddy heifer here's
what we know rumor has it Mitch the boss
is gonna give someone a raise today
based on the science we've already
discussed we are 100% sure that that
person will be a father who's the father
well they don't call me the Maury Povich
of science for nothing eat Tom Tom is a
new daddy
he's also the case study for today's
experiment tom is a good worker killing
it today a pretty good worker hey nice
haircut but there are cracks in the
surface
I'll be shadowing Tom today recording
his movements analyzing his work ethic
and I'll present those findings to the
boss in hopes of keeping a raise out of
a daddy's pocket it's about time and
uncle gotta raise a daddy in his natural
habitat
[Music]
can you believe this guy
let's take a look at the nests
[Music]
reading on company time
basically porn you think this is a game
no no no don't do it don't give him the
race he doesn't deserve it what are you
talking about sir the daddy bonus I
don't know anything about race I just
came over here to congratulate Mitch
he's gonna be a daddy daddy daddy daddy
daddy daddy daddy daddy
[Music]
so what did we learn today folks we
learned that dads aren't broken the
system's broken and until somebody
builds an indestructible robot to bring
down the man we have to keep that mind
hashtag not all dads hashtag I'm Tim
Duffy hashtag science
[Music]